you
hi everyone is cherry on chest calm and
I just got paired up playing a five-o
game against the tricky master let's try
D six
see what white throws at me here okay
tryam for a quickie five
you could play e5 straightaway and
welcome a queenless middle game but uh
I'll just go with this Bishop to e7 get
some standard moves in c6 is another
I should be on the lookout for a quick
punch against this guy Knight g4 I guess
they're intending on going queenside
that's interesting
I think I want to get in c6 right now
and then I want to be prepared to get my
coin off of the D file so because then
they'd be threatening to maybe take away
on e5 and my knight would be pinned to
my queen you seem a little bottled up
like where's this night going I guess
he's gunning for
f5
I wondered probably I will be going
kingside yeah let's just get on with
this
a quick B 5 B 4 could be a bit
disruptive to the c39 night nf5 time
let me get a quick move in Queen a5 get
out of the line of fire pressure on A to
B 5 B 4
it's a bit of a race type of position so
what to do
can I afford rook to e8 Knight f5 and
then back up the bishop
I think I want to get that kind of
reorganization in it's a little bit slow
but this night is soon to be a very very
strong piece so take a step to kind of
neutralize him
Bishop c5 okay let's sneak this in
I think I need to just start some action
really fast now my Brooke might be
exposed in some lines we will see chase
him away now maybe even give him a kick
right at this moment I'll push they
could take and then maybe Knight to h6
maybe I take like this actually
hmm I don't know for sure um you know
what let's give him a boot
down on time here also what about
what about a push right now is that
working
more developing move-in hmm
tricky bishop to be seven or maybe I'm
considering a push but I'd only give up
a five so so quick um yeah it's kind of
tough kind of tough
all right
you
I can need to make a move to 3000k
develop
be looking to capture and maybe push
next and converge on this square this is
a really tough piece okay so I'm going
to go straight in for this now I think I
need to take some action like
immediately
so let's see
is pinned
Bishop I have a lot of pressure on this
pawn now I could give him a kick and I
think I will right now they don't have
that dark square Bishop idea of a
capture are pushing Knight to h6 my
queen is a bit offsides
should have done this instead hmm okay
let's get my bishop on this diagonal
got their cheek their Jeep on can't move
okay I push in the center right now
I feel like I need to take some action
like that push takes and then they do
one more piece the one that's not flying
let's try for this and then maybe this
idea I have is covered enough there
isn't they have two pieces on that
though are they not just dropping this
right here they're ready to take and
then get at this point
hmm okay that bishops really really
strong
I don't like having to do this but I'm
going to give it a whirl I already feel
like there's a potential P sacrifice
that I could go forward with oh I just
dropped upon ouch
well that definitely is going to hurt
totally miss that
going to take they were on this and they
have ideas on f6
I really want to look to move my knight
open up my bishop but it's tough to
really go forward with anything right
around this point they're going to start
pushing hmm
this is just busted
not too much I could do
Knight to d7 yeah this is big trouble
my Queens unprotected tactically
vulnerable that could happen at any
moment
have six I'll be going here I pressure
on e5 so I'm expecting them to shut down
my bishop why are they giving me this
pawn oh that tactic I was talking about
they get to take with the knight
yeah now I'm down a piece I'll play on
for just a little bit more
some back rank ideas they should insert
a check to put my bishop in a pin and of
course they do
okay why are they giving me this night
I'm going to find out they give the
piece back for what exactly
Knight d5 into f6 is a little bit weird
hmm they could push and then jump in the
night here
they work that detail out fast
interesting yeah I think it's just
resigned by now 97 and clock situation
that was a that was well calculated
right there at the end to know that they
were going to give up this piece and
have this idea of f6 and 97 nice
okay i felt like i got rolld very easily
in that one what to add to Queen to f6
is a little bit weird but yeah they kept
the tension on e5 and I never really got
the the type of counter play I would I
would like to have here in the case of
opposite sides castling
you know because they're I mean they're
not behind development wise this is a
really strong piece maybe right around
here I could have done something
different I have to be super correct
right around this stage so I wonder what
the computer would be saying right
around here I think it's okay to take
like I did and push like I did right
here I think I need to definitely come
up with something better because what I
did was even though this night is really
pesky nf5
maybe I could just done not even budge
with my Jeep on and instead I play move
like rook to c8
because I kicked him away to what may
very well be a better square on e3
observing these two points and these
further advanced pawns that I have that
I you know I would like to get in c4 but
you know I just can't get that in with
the knight on III and the bishop on d3
so maybe a quick improvement here would
be to invite the rook into the action
right now rook to c8 and now I'm at
least threatening to push and then take
away on e4 so that's probably that I
think that this is the improvement and
it's very easy to just have them have
the position fall like dominoes after
something like this because I don't have
a great way forward it's kind of a kind
of tricky this is just stopped cold like
in the game with Bishop to c4 so I need
to be really timely in this middle game
position and I simply wasn't and while I
dropped the d6 pawn but it was difficult
that's what I was signing up for by
pushing well this pond was already
vulnerable
but whether my palm is on c6 or Seif c6
or c5 he's still vulnerable when I went
here yeah that's that's definitely one
he's super vulnerable but uh yeah I need
to be much more accurate in this middle
game position I just wasn't and you saw
it collapse first hand but let's dive
right in with the engine and see what
more we can take away from this one okay
this is where I want to be
so starts off as a pierce defense and I
guess this is known as the lion defense
after Knight B to d7 in this position
line it's saying lion defense anti
Philidor position okay this is my strong
point
so that's a big focus a lot of pressure
a lot of defense of this point in the
game
clean f3 is definitely in different move
for me to be sitting here more common
with my little experience of this
openings to throw the night there but
White has their sights set on Queen side
castles okay so as mentioned I wanted to
be sure to get my clean off of this uh D
file really quick so and I don't want to
give up the appointee v it's suggesting
to maybe take give up a five or play C 6
C six in the game right there
now castles so what does this holding is
just a little pull here for white clean
a 5 it's a fan of this is going to force
King to be one at some stage so
Knight g3 and is it okay with rook to e8
I felt like I needed to take some action
against a knight arriving here um yeah
maybe instead of devoting these two
moves to work around a knight and not
make a G pawn advance maybe I could just
play g6 foot boy that really needs to be
weighed really well because something
like g6 I'm really asking for a the H
Vaughn to be pushed right down my throat
it feels like that would really hurt me
h4 and h5 and maybe the computer at the
moment it doesn't appreciate this but I
don't know about moving upon at least at
this moment right here maybe if I have a
bit more development in like I did in
the game with g6 but hmm I think I would
still be revisiting this idea this
little reorganization rookie EA and
Bishop to FA to kind of neutralize the
knight play around him when he's on f5
so Bishop to f8 it wants to just get
right on with be five but hmm
an interesting point I also have to be
on the lookout for Queen to g3 a
combined attack against g7 so if I'm
playing b5 something like this would
concern me though I guess I have Knight
to h5 yeah I have Knight to h5 if I do
this now now there's this idea of 9 to
h6 and then picking up f7 at least and
who knows what more this is a collapsing
fast so this is something I have to be
on the lookout for the night by itself
is okay I could I could manage that but
the queen is right around the corner to
enter in with the attack against g7
okay so I backed up straight away
so it wasn't a fan of that I just want
to get on with b5 okay
King b1 b5 now Bishop d3 and is it okay
with how I reacted here so it's
something equal ish push and now I took
here now I played Bishop to d7 first it
wants to take on d4 first but I guess
this is okay as well h3 and now I took
on d4 it does like that move Bishop
takes and the follow up c5 is I mean
that's the idea I didn't put my Bishop
on b7 to not eventually open his eyes up
so and I get to do that with a punch so
and in a position type like this where
you know time is a big factor and you're
racing to attack one another's king I
think backing up with the bishop is
maybe something not to go forward with
in fact you can't do that because of the
pressure against e4 I have three
attackers and there's only two defenders
at this stage
so there isn't time to do anything but
capture on f6 really okay it's also
suggesting Queen to g3 but best is the
move played in the game to give up the
bishop for night this is a vulnerable
point eventually dropped that was that
was bad but okay Knight to g3 and now
this is right around where I was saying
route to CA is better than the game move
g6 it's a fan of Queen to c7 as well I
guess with similar idea to look to push
with c4 hmm so I'm expecting with my
next move after g6 that it's a it's
turning in White's favor so I was
suggesting Rick to see a
[Music]
think that rip to see it is better their
queen to c7 is better than Brooke to c8
maybe that she's you know done her job
of well getting out of the line of fire
and at least putting some pressure here
now that that supported well enough she
could play here supporting both of this
in providing some lateral defense
against my king
I don't know these are the kind of
reasoning things that I do you know
looking back with the engine I try to
assign or find differences between let's
say the top two suggestions by the
engine
steve is now suggesting Queen to d8 okay
I'm not going to touch that but I could
see Queen to c7 versus rook to c8 noting
a difference or two so after g6 you know
this is a
isn't any good night to e3 and it's
still even ish but there was a big drop
off it because it likes me here
it's preferring black with rip to c8 or
Queen to c7 hmm even Bishop to c6 now
but I guess I throw away some of this
advantage by chasing the night away from
f5 it's not and it's a bit a bit of a
surprising thing for me to see it's such
a good square for a night but
there's an argument for the III square
being very good too because it
interferes with what it is I would want
to do playing c4
Bishop to g7 I figured why not get him
on the long diagonal well there's a
reason for why not this is a vulnerable
point now f5 it just seems like they're
and they're they're getting there first
no Bishop to c4 I guess I could take
here huh
once the story was taking here Hel's it
as even I have three on this now that
the bishop is here so if I would have
captured on e4
Knight takes e4 Bishop takes e4 clean f4
it still holds it as even the thing is
that white is getting the open lines
first so upon investment by white isn't
so bad I mean this is this is hitting
really really fast
and I'm not really coordinating on any
one significant square towards the White
King suggests g5 okay that's a move I'm
not going to play g5
yeah g5 what's the point of g5 just to
make sure the F file doesn't open up
it still seems pretty scary to do that
too I mean what's the follow up here h6
clean the DA yeah
that's not that's not the first thought
that crosses my mind in this position
let's play g5 okay
anyhow I could have captured on e4 but
that I don't know it's messy for sure
and well this is just a even worse of
course this is the game losing move it's
completely blind to this and I was
fixated on trying to make a c4 advance
somehow get in there but yeah this was a
giant lemon Bishop to a6 and it's just
gone from there yeah that's a pretty
significant pond he's stopping this
advance in well when he's not around
that's going to hit just like it did in
the game and they finished up
really well here I was saying that I'm
tactically vulnerable because my queen
is unprotected and then I just walked
right into
taking on e5
yeah they could take and then just
recapture the night so this is just gone
from here I guess the one key
instructive moment here is the the queen
or the rook retreating to facilitate my
c4 advance on the Kings side but I
didn't get that in and it just collapsed
really really fast like t8 is good and
they calculated this pretty quick Knight
to f4 instead of moving the knight
um I guess he is kind of struggling to
find a square he could go to f1 that
seems like the more I mean it's a
backward move but you're saving the
night and there's less calculation
needed you're even throwing a punch it's
not like I could play here that night
still guarding that I was playing his
white I would probably just do this but
they had enough time to work out this
variation apparently they seem to pull
it off really fast it's good calculation
night they're combined with now f6
Knight to e7 is hitting and my king will
be flushed away
from defense of the bishop and it's
completely gone plus 11 and I did the
recent just resigned here
okay lesson learned is a bit interesting
to see that maybe in this kind of rare
case the f5 square is maybe not as
menacing as a knight would maybe be from
e3 sense in this specific case one where
we are working with opposite sides
castling the knight from e3 is
preventing what it is I would like to do
and that is expand towards the enemy
King if I get in c4 maybe then b3 is
around the corner and maybe I'm hitting
first I'm cracking open the King
position first but the timing was just
way off and it wasn't accurate when I
needed to be come middle game
okay well as usual feel free to leave
any feedback to this video in the
comment section below hope you're having
a great day and I will catch you soon
that's all for now take care
you